(static crackling)
(thoughtful music)
- Okay, greetings. Happy Thursday.
I would take us outside
except for the whole recording business,
which we can't take outside,
which makes me a little sad
because it's a beautiful day.
This has been one of
those New England falls
that they promise you with the nice days
and, like, the leaves
falling from the trees.
I was driving last night back from Boston,
and it was very dark and
I was on country roads
and there was nobody else out
there and it was very foggy,
and the leaves were kind of swirling down,
and I kept thinking, like,
there's going to be a guy
with no head in my rear view mirror,
like, riding me down on his black horse.
That really did make
me think of that story.
So thank you for being inside.
Thank you for coming to this lecture.
What we're going to try to do today is get
into interwar Poland and, in particular,
interwar Poland's Ukrainian question.
I'm going to start by setting the scene,
and then we'll spend
the rest of the lecture
trying to figure out how
that scene makes sense.
So here's the scene to imagine.
It's December of 1933.
A Polish border guard is at work,
but he's not at work
protecting the border.
He's at work carrying
someone, leading someone
towards the border to cross the border
into the Soviet Union,
into Soviet Ukraine,
not far from the Volhynian town of Dubno,
very close to border post 1,381.
The two men are speaking
to each other in Russian.
The border guard is the more assured,
the border crosser the less assured.
As they reach the border,
the border guard gives
the border crosser a gun.
The crosser nervously puts
the safety on and off.
The border guard gives the
border crosser a white coat
so he can't be seen in the snow.
He gives him a compass and reminds him
that in Polish compasses,
the black is the north end of the needle.
And with these supplies and
with a few words of reassurance,
the border crosser makes his way
across the border into the Soviet Union.
How does it come to that?
I mean, isn't it interesting
that Poland is sending people illegally
into the Soviet Union in 1933?
What kind of Poland is doing that?
What are Poland's aims?
So let's start with what kind of Poland,
because now that we're
into the 1920s and 1930s,
the territorial distribution
of Ukraine has changed again,
as we said at the end of the last lecture.
Most of what's now Ukraine
is inside the Soviet Union
as a republic which is named Ukraine.
Much of what is now Ukraine, in particular
districts called Galicia
or Volhynia, Galicja,
Wolyn, Halychyna, Volyn,
are inside Poland.
So there's a new east-west division.
There are five or six million people
who speak Ukrainian who
are now inside Poland,
roughly 15% of the population of Poland,
which is a pretty sizable
national minority.
For comparison, that's two or
three percentage points more
than there are African
Americans in the United States.
So we have to contend now with Poland.
If we don't understand Poland,
we can't understand the
position of these Ukrainians,
but we also can't understand
how the Poles might be trying
to answer the Ukrainian question.
So you'll all remember Poland
had been a great power.
There was this thing
called the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth
that existed from 1569 to 1795.
You'll remember from just
a couple lectures ago
that the collapse of the
Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth
in the late 18th century
is the central part
of the advance of the
Russian Empire into Europe.
The late 18th century is
the time of the collapse
of the Crimean Khanate.
It's the time of the collapse
of the Ukrainian Cossack state,
and it's also the time of the collapse
of the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth.
So the late 18th century is the moment
when Russia becomes a European power,
which is symbolized with a shift
of the capital from
Moscow to St. Petersburg,
actually the creation of St. Petersburg,
which Pushkin famously calls a window,
a window into Europe.
So the Polish-Lithuanian
Commonwealth is gone,
but it has left certain
very important legacies
for Ukrainians.
I mean, I've stressed this
point over and over again,
but it's very important to remember
that most of Ukraine was
connected to Lithuania or Poland
much longer than it was connected
with the Russian Empire
or the Soviet Union.
So just these hundreds of years
that we've spent studying
that, that's a sort of legacy.
But I'll mention three
particular political legacies.
One would be the existence
of the Cossacks themselves.
So it's not as though the
Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth
created the Cossacks,
but the Cossacks existed
in a particular form
inside and at the edge
of the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth.
A second is the general idea of a republic
as a state form, right?
So when Ukrainians try
to found states in 1918,
they take the form of republics.
They take the name of republics.
That is in some way natural
because it's the European norm,
but it's also natural because a republic
is also an important part
of Ukrainian history.
A third legacy is the rule of law.
So the rule of law in the
Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth
didn't apply to everybody.
It applied to the nobility.
The Cossacks were well aware of this,
which is why they wanted to
be treated like the nobility,
and much of the conflict
between the Cossacks
and the Polish state had
to do with the rights
of the Cossacks, that Cossacks
should have some kind
of rights vis-a-vis the state.
They were dissatisfied
with their legal position,
but they were aware that it was a state
which had the rule of law,
and that is also a kind of legacy.
Okay, so in the case of Ukraine,
I've tried to make the argument,
a little bit counterintuitive,
that it was a good thing
to be divided, right?
So it always seems painful
and it lends itself to images of martyrdom
when, you know, the
national body is divided
into multiple pieces and so on.
But if you're going to
be occupied by empires,
I'm not recommending this,
but if you're going to
be occupied by empires,
there are certain political advantages
to being occupied by more
than one empire, right?
So just logically speaking,
one of them is going to be
less repressive than the other.
I mean, that may be a slightly
depressing way to look at it,
but one of them will be less
suppressive than the other,
and it's always possible
that the two of them will
in some way compete over you, right?
Or they'll try to use
you against the other,
which might turn out to be
to your long-term advantage.
I tried to explain the dynamics of this
with the Habsburgs and the Russian Empire.
With Poland, there's a similar situation,
but the Polish-Lithuanian
Commonwealth is divided
between three empires.
It's divided between Prussia,
which becomes United Germany,
and this is a big story which
is sort of on the periphery
of what we've been talking about,
but it keeps becoming more central.
Like, you can ignore
the Germans for a while,
but eventually, they make their way
to the center of your attention.
I mean, that's kind of a general truth,
but it's true in this class.
So we started with this little state,
Royal Prussia, on the Baltic,
which the Polish-Lithuanian
Commonwealth kind of tolerates.
After the ruin, after the weakening
of the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth,
this little state Prussia
decides that it's a kingdom.
It decides that its
ruling family are kings.
That state, Prussia,
will become much larger
in the 18th century,
and in the 19th century,
that state Prussia, in 1870,
1871, will unite Germany,
will create a unified German state.
So the partitioning power of
Poland is actually not Germany,
which doesn't exist yet, but Prussia.
But when Prussia unites Germany in 1871,
the Poles are then the most
important national minority
inside that new German state,
and they're subject to
various repressive policies,
which they respond to in a
way which we would think of
as involving organized civil society.
So the Germans try to buy up all the land.
The Poles organize their own groups
to collect money and to preserve the land.
The Germans try to build libraries.
The Poles build libraries.
The Germans Germanize the schools.
The Poles set up their
own reading societies.
The Poles publish their books.
So there's a certain style of
resistance in German Poland.
We've talked a bit about the Habsburgs.
The Habsburgs are the second
partitioning power of Poland.
In the Habsburg monarchy,
other conditions prevail,
and the Polish gentry,
the Polish nobility,
are able to gain experience as
administrators, bureaucrats.
Some of them are elected to parliament.
They gain experience of freedom of speech.
They gain experience of
publishing as they wish.
All of that experience will also matter
for a reunited Poland later on.
Most of what had been Poland becomes part
of the Russian Empire, and there,
the political tradition is
much more revolutionary,
as one would expect.
The kinds of things that were possible
in the Habsburg monarchy
or even in Prussia
are not possible in the Russian Empire.
The only kinds of politics
that are really possible
in the Russian Empire are underground,
very well organized, conspiratorial,
which leads to certain habits of mind
and certain habits of practice.
So you have three different traditions,
all of which have advantages
and disadvantages,
coming together in Poland
when it is created in 1918.
One more advantage I
should really mention.
So as I'm sure many of you
have been thinking about,
an interesting feature
of the war in Ukraine now
is that the people on the
Ukrainian side know the language
of the aggressing state, right?
So basically all the Poles
I'm going to be talking
about in this lecture
are native or close to
native speakers of Russian.
And so in a tale which is going
to be largely about espionage,
this matters an awful lot, right?
So all the Poles that I'm
going to be talking about
in this lecture, with maybe
one or two exceptions,
were educated in the Russian Empire
and went through Russian schools
and therefore as adults
in the '20s and '30s
were native or very close
to native Russian speakers.
Some of them have spent time in Siberia,
like Jozef Pilsudski, which only, I mean,
that improves your Russian
in certain ways, right?
I mean, it gives you the prison part
of the Russian language,
which can come in handy.
Okay, so the two main traditions
in Polish politics that had formed
by 1918 already are the
Polish Socialist Party,
in Polish, the PPS, Polska
Partia Socjalistyczna,
PPS on your sheets, and
the National Democrats.
So interestingly, the two poles, sorry,
in Polish political life, it
wasn't intended as a joke,
it just came out that way,
are already established
before there's a Polish state.
And these two poles are
basically the same today,
by the way.
It's a very coherent development.
So the Polish Socialist Party
is obviously center left.
Its dominant view is there
should be a state first
and then we'll build socialism later.
The Polish Socialist Party
tends to be nostalgic
towards the old
commonwealth and to believe
that some future Poland
will be a federation,
not a nation-state, so a kind
of modernized commonwealth
in which the Belarusian, Lithuanian,
Ukrainian nations will somehow be present
and in which the Jews will
have some kind of autonomy.
That's the idea.
On the center right,
the National Democrats,
there's a very different vision.
Their attitude towards the history
of Poland is very different.
The National Democrats say,
"Forget about the commonwealth.
It fell. It was worthless.
The nobility was not the nation.
The nation is really the peasants.
They just don't know it yet.
Our job is to take the
Polish-speaking peasants
and to make them into Poles.
That's what a movement is for.
That's what the state is for.
We're not concerned about the Germans
and the Jews and the Ukrainians and so on.
They're not really Poles.
They probably never will be Poles.
Maybe the Belarusians
and Ukrainians will be,
but certainly not the
Germans and the Jews."
So their attitude is very different.
The Germans and the Jews
are national enemies,
and the Slavs are maybe assimilable,
but if they're not assimilable,
then they can also be national enemies.
The National Democrats are
thinking about a nation-state.
They're thinking about a nation-state
where the nation in question
is the Polish nation.
So these are the two
currents in Polish politics
which are already present,
and when I tell the story
of the '20s and '30s, it's
really these two currents
which are going to be
alternating in power,
very much like today.
Okay, so Poland,
unlike Ukraine, at the end
of the First World War,
is regarded by the Entente as an ally.
This is really important.
By the Entente, of
course, I mean the French,
the British, the Americans,
the victorious Western powers.
In the Paris peace settlements,
they regard some countries
as effectively their allies
and some countries not,
and this is only vaguely
related to what actually happens
during the war itself,
and it has a lot to do
with the interests of those countries,
especially France, in the years to come.
So the French take the most punishment
in the First World War.
It's largely fought on French territory.
The French are most concerned
about the balance of power
on the continent after
the First World War.
The peace talks are held in Paris
or in nice spa towns around Paris nearby.
And it's generally French
interests that prevail.
In Poland, you have an overlap
of the principle that was announced,
national self-determination.
Woodrow Wilson specifies
that Poland will become
an independent state.
So the principle of national
self-determination is applied.
But also France wants Poland to exist
because France wants an ally
to the east of Germany, right?
If you are France...
I'm trying to think of, like...
You're playing Risk, right? Okay.
So if you're France,
you always want the ally
to the east of Germany,
and if you're Germany,
you're always afraid of, right?
It's that classical situation.
So if you're France,
you're not so concerned
about who that is and
what their regime is.
France had been allies
with the Russian Empire,
right, for this reason.
So the Russian Empire is done with,
and what do the French do?
The French say independent
Poland, and they ally
or they try to support the
Whites in the Russian Civil War.
So they're supporting
the pro-imperial forces
in the Russian Civil War.
They lose, as we already know,
but that's what the
French we're banking on.
So the French want allies
to the east of Germany.
So those two things
come together this time,
principle and practice,
in the creation of Poland.
So the Western allies are
going to support the creation
of Poland, not that the Poles
don't fight for it, they do,
but they have two things
which the Ukrainians don't.
Nobody is saying that
Ukraine has the right
to self-determination
except for Germany in 1918,
and that doesn't count for very much,
and nobody thinks that the
existence of a Ukrainian state
is in their strategic
interests except for Poland,
and that in a very limited sense,
which we're going to get to.
Okay, so this brings us to,
you know, the basic relationship,
it's kind of an
intellectually beautiful thing
to think about, the relationship
between a revolution and borders, right?
Because a revolution doesn't have borders.
A revolution is a total transformation.
When you talk about a
revolution, you don't say
"I want a revolution
in my backyard," right?
You don't say, "I want a..."
A revolution is about
total transformation.
So the French Revolution wasn't,
I mean, it was about France,
but it was also about invading
the rest of Europe, right?
Because it was about principles.
The Russian Revolution, as
we talked about last time,
was not meant to be about Russia at all.
It was meant to be a global revolution
which just happened to take
a starting point in Russia.
But then we get to the
very practical question
of what happens when the revolution
that you've made turns
out not to be global.
Where does it end, then, right?
That very mundane question.
Where does it end?
And that question is going
to be decided largely
by the use of force between Poland
and the Soviet Union in 1919 and 1920.
So if we think of the stretch of territory
between the Baltic Sea and the Black Sea,
Estonia, Lithuania,
Latvia, Belarus, Ukraine,
that stretch of territory
is a kind of power vacuum
at the end of the First World War.
The Entente has won the war,
but they won it on the Western Front.
The German Army was exhausted
on the Western Front.
The German Army is
exhausted fighting in France
against the Americans, the
British, and the French.
So the Germans lose, but they lose the war
having never been defeated in the East,
which is an odd situation and
very important for everybody.
From a Western point of view,
it's easy to forget about.
But from an East European point of view
or even a German point
of view, it's central.
It's central to the
Nazis, by the way, too.
It's central to everything
that's going to come next.
From the point of view of
German soldiers in the East,
there never was a defeat.
They just had to come home at some point.
They were never beaten.
They just had to come home. Okay.
So after 1918, there's a power vacuum
because there's been been a revolution.
In 1917, the Russian Revolution
destroys the Russian Empire.
In 1918, the German and
Austrian armies move in
to support their version of Ukraine,
and then they're defeated,
so they move back out.
And what's left is a vacuum
which, on the Polish side,
Jozef Pilsudski, who is the leader
of the Polish Socialist
Party and also the leader
of the Polish state, wishes to
fill, and on the other side,
Vladimir Lenin, the leader
of the Bolshevik party
and de facto of the Russian
state, also wants to fill.
But the interesting idea here
which I want you to notice
is that neither of them wants to fill it
on behalf of nation-states.
That's not the kind of
idea they have in mind.
Lenin is thinking of a global...
Where did I lose you?
Know that I'm sensing confusion
in the middle of the room.
No? You're okay?
You're fine? Okay.
They can't edit that out, by the way.
That's going to be on the video.
It's there forever.
So Pilsudski is thinking
about some kind of vague federation.
He's not thinking Poland for the Poles.
That's not his idea at all.
His idea is somehow the
Lithuanians, the Belarusians,
and the Ukrainians somehow
also in this, right?
Whether they would be equal
partners or not is less clear,
but somehow, some kind of larger state
which is not just Poland for the Poles.
He wants more Lithuanians,
more Belarusians,
more Ukrainians, more Jews in the state.
Lenin's idea is also not...
Obviously it's not a nation-state.
Lenin's idea is global revolution.
And so by the moment
we're talking about, 1919,
it's already clear that
the world isn't going
to have a revolution just
because Russia did, okay?
And this is the key to the, like...
This is like the original sin,
if you want, of the Soviet Union,
or it's the key to how
things work out later,
because Lenin and Trotsky, the Bolsheviks,
they didn't think they were
starting a Russian revolution.
They thought that they were the powder keg
for a global revolution.
Then what do you do when the
global revolution doesn't come?
Well, your next move is to say,
"Okay, we're going to
help it along," right?
"We're going to help it along."
So once they have won
the Russian Civil War,
their next move is to think,
"We're going to go into Europe
and we'll help out the German
comrades, because obviously,
Germany's the most
important country in Europe.
If we can get to Berlin,
then there can be revolution in Germany,
and then there will be world revolution."
So stage one is,
your theory is there should
be global revolution.
Stage two is that your practice is,
you've got to get to Europe
and help out the German comrades.
But what's in the way? Poland.
And the Poles aren't just in the way.
They're moving east.
So this sets up the Polish-Bolshevik
War of 1919 to 1920.
As I mentioned last time, the
furthest the Poles ever get
in this war is Kyiv in May of 1920,
the victory in Kyiv with the,
you know, the circular march
of the Polish cavalry around Khreshchatyk.
That is followed by the
Red Army's march on Warsaw,
where what's called the miracle,
the Vistula, the Poles' defeat...
It's called the miracle.
The Vistula is the river
that runs through Poland.
The miracle on the Vistula was
originally sarcastic, like,
in the sense of "after what
you did, we needed a miracle"
because this war was contested
inside Poland itself.
The National Democrats,
the right, opposed the war.
They didn't want to
expand Polish territory.
They wanted the nation-state, right?
And so for them, this was
a dangerous adventure.
"Why are we going all the way to Kyiv?
Look what you did.
You brought the Red Army
to the suburbs of Warsaw.
We need a miracle."
But that sarcastic miracle on the Vistula
eventually became a non-sarcastic
miracle on the Vistula.
It's now just a kind of neutral
name of the achievement.
So the Poles hold off the Red Army
at the gates of Warsaw, basically,
and stage a very successful counterattack,
drive the Red Army deep
into Ukraine and to Belarus,
at which point both sides are exhausted
and a peace is signed,
and that's the Treaty of
Riga of March of 1921.
So the Treaty of Riga creates an effect...
And you know, and this is
something to think about
when a war is being fought.
Where the border is in
large measure defines
what kind of states are
then going to exist.
Because on the Polish side,
what you end up getting
is not a federation.
It's not big enough for that.
There are a lot of Belarusians, a million.
There are a lot of
Ukrainians, five million plus.
There are a lot of Jews, three million.
But there aren't enough
for a federation, right?
This is a state, nevertheless,
which has a clear majority
of Polish speakers,
and so what it becomes
is a Polish nation-state
with big national minorities.
It's not exactly what the
National Democrats wanted
and it's also not what Pilsudski wanted,
but that's what the
borders of Riga create.
They create this Poland with
big national minorities,
substantial national minorities.
On the Soviet side,
what the Treaty of Riga does
is that it creates a border.
It means the revolution has stopped.
For now, at least, the
revolution has a border,
which is to say the Soviet
Union has to become a state,
which it does.
And the Bolsheviks are making
this up as they go along.
They're making this up as they go along,
their response to the defeat.
And they were defeated.
The Poles defeated them.
They're not going to be defeated again
until Afghanistan in 1979,
but the Red Army is
defeated by Poland in 1920.
And so the response to Polish
defeat is to create this thing
that we take for granted,
which is the Soviet Union.
The Soviet Union is the state
which contains the revolution.
So it's not supposed to be a normal state.
It's not a nation-state.
From the Soviet, from the
Bolshevik point of view,
it's certainly not an empire.
It's something completely new.
It's a kind of container for revolution,
a revolution which at some
later date will get spread
throughout the world.
In the meantime, it becomes the task
of the Soviet comrades to
complete the revolution
inside their own borders and
to model it for everyone else.
Okay, so now that's,
so in Poland, what follows from this
is a certain fundamental
difficulty for democracy.
In Poland, you have two basic questions
which make parliamentary
democracy difficult
right from the beginning.
One of them and the most
important is the land question.
And I realize I keep beating
you over the head with this,
but in the first half of the 20th century,
land was the most important
question in politics,
not anything else but land,
because most people in
the part of the world
that we're studying, at
least, were peasants,
and in general, they wanted to
have more land than they did.
This was still an economy,
and we're, you know,
in much the world, it's
still true, but in Europe,
in our part of Europe,
this is still an economy
where most people have small plots of land
and want to have bigger plots of land
or have no land and
want to have more land.
And because, you know...
The economy itself is
still agrarian, right?
This is the center of politics.
If you want to, you
can think of everything
that happens in Poland, Soviet
Union, and even Nazi Germany
as an answer to the land question,
where the Poles try to do
land reform and kind of fail.
Land reform means you take
from people who have more land,
give it to people who have less land.
The Soviets at the end of
the day take everyone's land
and create collective farming.
Even Hitler's ideas that you
should invade Eastern Europe
and take the land, that's a solution
to the land question, right?
So the key to a lot of this is land,
people wanting more land.
So in Polish politics,
as in Eastern Europe,
as in democratic Eastern
Europe in general,
the key question was land,
and the difficulty was trying
to get the peasants
interested in politics,
trying to get the peasants to see
that democratic politics
somehow serves their interests.
And the best way to do
that is land reform, right?
That's something the state can do for you
if you're a peasant.
It can take some land from
your wealthy neighbor,
from that person
who owned the plantation
that your grandfather was a serf in,
take some land from that
person and give it to you.
That's something the state can do.
The Poles do that to some degree.
But here's where the
national question comes in.
In Poland, there was a peasant party,
but it was a Polish peasant party, right?
It wasn't just a peasant party.
This is really, really, really important.
There was no class party
for the peasants of Poland.
And even more than in the Polish areas,
in the Belarusian and Ukrainian areas,
most people were peasants.
So this means that basically,
in democratic elections,
the Belarusian and Ukrainian
peasants were excluded
because there was no
party they could vote for
which really had a chance
of exercising any kind of influence.
Had there been a peasant
party representing peasants
as such, that party would've
won every time, right?
But there was no such
party, and so therefore,
everything switches around,
and if you're a Belarusian peasant
or a Ukrainian peasant, you can think,
"Well, the Polish peasants
seem to be getting some land,
but I don't seem to be
getting any land," right?
And so then the land question is magnified
by the national question.
And this is one of the ways
that Polish politics turns
in the first half of the 1920s where,
when Poland is being ruled by coalitions
of National Democrats and the
Polish Peasant Party, right?
So you can see the setup for this.
The setup for this means that you have,
if you're the Soviet Union,
we'll talk more about this,
but if you're the Soviet
Union looking at Poland,
there is a huge opening for you.
You can speak to Ukrainians
and to Belarusians
about national liberation,
and you can speak to
them about land reform.
Now obviously, at the end of the day,
we know that the Soviet Union is not going
to be the homeland of national
liberation or land reform.
But in the 1920s, this was propaganda.
This was an approach that
the Soviets could take.
And in the 1920s, it
seemed pretty reasonable,
we're going to talk more about
this, because in the 1920s,,
the Soviets were engaged in something
Poland was not engaged in,
which was affirmative
action for Ukrainians,
giving Ukrainians
educational opportunities,
building schools and universities,
pulling Ukrainians up
through the ranks of the administration.
They were also engaged in
allowing Ukrainian peasants
to keep the land they took
from Polish landlords.
So this is a very basic way that Poland
and the Soviet Union
were different, right?
In the revolution, 1917, '18,
a lot of what happens in Ukraine,
especially Right-bank Ukraine,
is that Ukrainian peasants take land
from historic Polish landlords
and then those historic
Polish landlords flee west
to Poland, which from the
point of view of Poland
is ethnic cleansing and oppression, right?
But from the point of view
of the Ukrainian peasants,
it's "We finally got the land
that we've been working."
And so from the point of
view of a Ukrainian peasant,
that was a good revolution, right?
That was a good revolution.
That was a revolution or
a part of the revolution
that we want to keep.
And in the 1920s, the
Bolsheviks were not able
to do anything about that
and so they allowed it to maintain itself.
That was called the New Economic Policy.
So in the 1920s, Ukrainian
peasants got more land,
they got fewer Polish landlords,
and Ukrainian educated people
were getting affirmative action,
none of which existed in Poland, right?
So in the 1920s, if
you're the Soviet Union,
you can make propaganda against Poland
because of these basic realities.
Okay, in Poland, there is,
if we get more specific now,
there is a big difference
between the two Ukrainian districts,
and now we're getting to the stuff that,
like, 30 years down the line,
you're going to be making
cocktail party conversation with
when you explain to people
about the difference
between Galicia and Volhynia, right?
And you guys are already
halfway there because you know,
(laughing) because you know
that Galicia is the part
that came from the
Habsburg monarchy, right?
You know that the name Galicia, Galizien,
was invented basically by the Habsburgs
to name territory they took in 1772
and that territory, Galicia,
ends up being part of Poland.
The Poles call it something
completely different.
They call it Malopolska
Wschodnia, Eastern Little Poland.
But it's the eastern part of Galicia.
Volhynia is something very different.
Volhynia has been part
of the Russian Empire
this entire time.
Volhynia has been part
of the Russian Empire
for more than a hundred years.
In Volhynia, unlike Galicia,
people belong to the Orthodox Church,
not the Greek Catholic Church.
In Volhynia, there are far fewer Poles
and fewer Jews than there are in Galicia,
and also the standard of
comparison is very different.
So one of the main problems
for the Poles trying to govern Galicia
is that if you're a Galician
Ukrainian, after 1918,
everything got worse for
you in a couple of ways.
So politics is very
much about expectations.
If you're a Ukrainian in
Galicia, you might have expected
"We are going to get our own state"
because between November of
1918 and the spring of 1919,
there was a West Ukrainian
National Republic,
and it was defeated by none other
than the Polish Army, right?
And so if you're a Ukrainian,
that's a disappointment, right?
And there's nothing the Polish
state can do to repair that,
because from the point of
view of the Polish state,
this is Polish territory.
The second frame of reference
is the Habsburg monarchy.
So if we're going to be
governed by someone else,
we're used to having certain
things, freedom of speech,
freedom of assembly,
free political parties.
We're used to having schools.
We're used to being able to
serve in the administration.
Under Polish rule, a lot
of that will be taken away.
There will be fewer
Ukrainian-speaking schools.
Ukrainians in general will be excluded
from the state administration in Poland,
which they were not in
the Habsburg monarchy.
The Greek Catholic Church
will not be treated as equal.
So in all these ways, the positions
of Ukrainians in Galicia is actually worse
than it was in the Habsburg monarchy,
and they're very well aware of this,
and they're used to talking about this.
And it's not easy for
them to situate themselves
in the Polish state.
Eventually by the late 1930s
when things are very bad,
the main position among
Ukrainians will be something
like "Poland is better
than the alternatives."
But better than the alternatives
is not a rallying cry
for everyday politics in general.
So the main force in Ukrainian politics
is something called Undo,
U-N-D-O, it's on your sheet,
which takes a kind of centrist position,
not sure about the Polish
state in the 1920s.
Many people thinking
that maybe the Soviet
Union might be better,
feeling left out of Polish
politics with justification.
There is a right-wing
fraction, a very small group,
called the OUN, the Organization
of Ukrainian Nationalists,
which is a typical, looking
at this from the point of view
of, you know, political science,
a typical reaction to
exclusion from democracy.
If, you know, if you go
from a more democratic
to a less democratic situation,
there will probably be
some group which decides
that the answer to this is violence
against the institutions, and that group
is the Organization of
Ukrainian Nationalists.
In interwar Poland, they
were not very significant.
They were not very numerous.
The Poles did a pretty good
job of locking them up.
They did assassinate a few
Polish officials after 1926.
In general, they
assassinated, as one does,
the people who were in favor of some kind
of accommodation or compromise, right?
You don't assassinate the
radicals on the other side.
I mean, I feel like I'm now
giving you a training course,
so don't take it that way,
but you see the logic, right?
You assassinate the
moderates on the other side
because if you're a radical,
you prefer the radicals on the other side.
You prefer conflict.
You don't want the compromisers
because the compromisers might make a deal
with your compromisers and
then you'd be out of business
and your radical vision wouldn't seem
like it makes a lot of sense.
I mentioned the OUN because
it'll become more important
during the war, but it's
actually not that important
during the '20s and '30s.
So the early '20s in Poland are a time
of democratic politics
in which the land question
is only very unsatisfactorily answered
and the national question,
if you're not Polish,
is not answered at all.
This changes a bit in 1926.
In 1926, Poland becomes
much less democratic,
but the people who come
to power are more open
on the national question.
In 1926, Jozef Pilsudski,
the former head of state,
comes back to power by
way of a military coup
and installs what we, I think,
would be very comfortable calling,
borrowing some Russian terminology,
a managed democracy, right?
I mean, it's managed better
than the current Russian
democracy, non-democracy, is.
But there are political parties.
There is voting.
There's a certain amount
of massaging of the vote.
of disenfranchisement.
It's kind of a democracy,
but you also kind of already
know who's going to win
before the elections take place.
So he overthrows a democracy,
installs a kind of managed democracy
with his own political party and then,
you know, governs from behind the scenes.
It's not really a dictatorship,
but it's an authoritarian regime.
From our point of view,
the difference here,
the relevant difference,
if you remember between,
you know, the basic orientations,
center left, center right,
the center left is more open
on the national question,
more tolerant of Jews, more
open on the national question.
And what Pilsudski then begins to do,
with no democratic legitimation,
this is never talked about at all,
everything I'm about to talk
about was kept entirely secret
from the Polish population,
with no democratic legitimation,
he then undertakes a policy of trying
to tolerate the Ukrainian
national identity
in part of Poland, partly with the hope
of undoing Soviet influence.
So the Soviet influence,
as I've already tried to
suggest, was very real.
The Soviets in the 1920s
are in a rather beautiful
strategic situation
with respect to Poland, as
I've already tried to suggest.
In 1923, the Soviets
promulgate their doctrine
on colonialism and nationalism,
which is very clever.
It basically says that
nationalism is reactionary
inside the Soviet Union but
outside the Soviet Union
is progressive, right?
Which is a very convenient position.
So, you know, it's the Leninist view
of national self-determination that,
sure, everybody has a right in principle
to a nation-state, it just...
In practice, it depends
on whether this serves us or not, right?
So anti-colonial movements
in India are great, right?
As are anti-colonial
movements in Poland. Super.
Anti-colonial movements in Central Asia
or the Caucasus or
Ukraine, not at all, right?
But so what this allows them to do
is it allows them to use
the national question
and the question of land against Poland
but also against the British Empire.
I mean, the Soviets were engaged
with the British Empire as well.
But for our purposes,
Poland is what matters.
So what they do is that they
try to present Soviet Ukraine
as a sovereign Ukrainian state
where peasants have land,
where there are national freedoms,
and try in this way to draw the millions
of Ukrainians in Poland
towards the Soviet Union
and destabilize the Polish state.
And as I say, this was carried out
with a great deal of success.
What Pilsudski does is that
he tries to reverse this.
So in Galicia, he never has a chance.
In Galicia, there is already,
when they come to power in '26,
the Ukrainian nationalists
assassinate the Polish officials
and you get a spiral of
reprisals and counter-reprisals
which discredit the
Polish state in Galicia.
In any event, in Galicia,
there just wasn't a kind of
fresh terrain to work in.
What they do is they take Volhynia
and they try to educate a generation
of pro-Polish Ukrainians in Volhynia.
They carry out a policy known
as the Volhynian Experiment
from 1928, led by a man
called Henryk Jozewski,
who's on your sheet.
And what Jozewski does is a kind of,
it's kind of a capitalist or a bourgeois
or a liberal version of
Soviet affirmative action.
So he places Ukrainians
in Volhynia in local government.
He encourages the use of
the Ukrainian language
in the Orthodox Church.
He encourages a movement
towards autocephaly in the
Ukrainian Orthodox Church
on Polish territory.
And he talks about Ukrainian independence.
He talks about a replay of
the Polish-Bolshevik War
in which this time, Poland would win
and the creation of a Ukrainian state.
Now, Jozewski was a true
believer in all of this.
He was from Kyiv.
He was authentically in
love with Ukrainian culture
and songs, literature.
He spoke Ukrainian like a native.
He deeply believed that Ukrainian
and Polish culture were
fundamentally very similar
and that Russian culture
was something different.
But in general, one of
course has to ask, you know,
one has to be a little
bit critical all the same.
Is this idea of Ukraine, you know,
is it for the Ukrainians
or is it about creating a buffer state?
Because if you're Poland,
it's better to have something
between you and Russia.
And for the Poles who were involved,
it was a mixture of motives.
I mean, there was certainly
idealism involved,
but there was also this
notion that it would be better
to have Ukraine for our
own strategic interests.
So what the Poles do is under the cover
of this toleration project,
they're also educating young Ukrainians,
training them for espionage missions
inside Soviet Ukraine.
And they also, and this
is not widely known,
but they also revive a
government in exile for Ukraine.
They revive the Ukrainian
National Republic
on their own territory.
They set up a staff for
a Ukrainian army in 1927
with sections for propaganda
and for intelligence.
And in 1928, this Ukrainian
army on Polish soil begins
to run its agents across
the Soviet border.
From the point of view of Poland,
this is part of a larger project
which is known as Prometheanism.
And this, again, you should, like...
It's a really interesting
point of contrast
to Poland of today.
A lot of the ideas that
I'm talking about now
have a faint echo in Polish policy today,
but it's a pretty faint echo.
The Poles in the '20s and '30s
were a lot more adventurous
on these issues than
the Polish state is now.
The idea of Prometheanism
was national self-determination,
national self-determination
for the oppressed nations
of the Soviet Union.
And so the Poles,
in secret, this was not an
open-forum policy at all,
but in secret, they funded and helped
with the publications
of and sometimes helped
run people across borders
for Caucasian nations,
for Georgia, for Chechens,
and also for Ukrainians.
And the basic idea of this
is that it's trying to flip
what the Soviets are saying.
So the Soviets are saying,
"We have national self-determination.
Look at our beautiful national liberation.
Look at these republics."
And the Poles are saying, "No, actually,
the national question is your weakness,
and there are all these
immigrant politicians
who agree with us and we're
going to support them."
And this larger policy of
Prometheanism had connections
with the British and the French and even,
interestingly, in the
Japanese, all of whom,
for their various reasons, had reasons
to try to weaken the Soviet Union.
Now, so up until 1933,
if you read the files, which,
one summer, I was able to do...
There was a summer when the
Polish military archives
were entirely closed, but for some reason,
they let me just sit
there and read them all,
which was great.
I literally used a shopping cart,
which is not normal archival practice.
I had a shopping cart and I
filled up the shopping cart
with files, and then I read all the files,
and then I went and got
another shopping cart.
That is the research
which is in "Sketches from a Secret War,"
and that is why there's a lot
in "Sketches from a Secret War"
which you're not going
to find anywhere else.
But the general drift, as you'll see
when you do the reading, is
that from 1926 to 1931, '32,
there's some really interesting
Polish intelligence work
going on in Ukraine
under this overall auspice
of the Volhynian Experiment,
under this overall
auspice of Prometheanism.
We know a lot about the
agents and the rings
that the Poles were running
inside Soviet Ukraine
led by this man
with the close-to-unpronounceable
name of Jerzy Niezbrzycki,
who is a very interesting character.
He, like a lot of these men and women,
because a lot of the agents and officers
in Polish intelligence,
by the way, were women,
was a Pole from Ukraine, so
someone who knew the territory,
knew the languages, was bilingual.
Some of them were trilingual.
So he ran these agents,
and one of the stories which stays with me
because it reveals an
important difference is...
So a lot of this stuff is about sex.
I don't know how you guys feel about that.
Like, is it okay to talk
about sex? (laughing)
I wish I could share with the camera,
like, the various reactions that that got.
So a lot of the operations involve sex,
so Polish male officers
having sex with Soviet women
and Polish female officers
having sex with Soviet men,
or they involve relationships
in which sex is somehow
in the picture, right?
And so there's one example
which I found really
interesting because it gets us
to a kind of difference
between two systems
is when one of Niezbrzycki's
female friends,
who was a Polish intelligence officer
operating inside Ukraine...
This is not going to be
directly about sex. I'm sorry.
It's all in the reading, though.
If you get, like, deep into the reading,
you'll find there's a
lot of sex with spies.
Okay.
But so he had a friend
who I'm going to call X22,
and what she did
was she exchanged consumer goods,
in particular nylon stockings,
which was something which
was trivially easy to get
in Poland but which did not
exist in the Soviet Union.
She would trade nylon stockings
and other similar things
for files and books from, you know,
her female friends' mail, like,
from their husbands' libraries
and their filing cabinets, right?
That was one of her methods.
She had other methods of
operation, it's in the reading,
but that was one of her
methods of operation.
And what this reveals,
you'll see where I'm going,
is that by 1931, '32,
we really have two very different systems.
Poland is a capitalist country.
It's a poor capitalist country.
It's a capitalist country.
In the Soviet Union, by 1931, 1932,
we are in the middle of collectivization,
which will be our big subject next time.
We're the middle of a
transformation of the Soviet Union
into a form of industrialized country,
which involves taking all of
the land away from the peasants
and putting them under
the control of the state.
And it is in this moment
of collectivization,
especially '28, '29, '30,
that Soviet Ukraine is
probably most at risk.
In early 1930, the Soviet
secret police records
more than one million acts
of individual resistance
by peasants on the territory
of the Ukrainian Republic
against collectivization, and
it's during this time also
that thousands upon thousands
of Ukrainian peasants
or peasants from Soviet
Ukraine flee to Romania
and flee to Poland to
escape collectivization.
And when they come to Poland,
they plea for war.
So, I mean, we'll talk more
about it in the next lecture,
but it is a very dramatic situation
to suddenly lose your land
and to see everyone else losing their land
and to realize that you have no recourse.
So just to quote one peasant...
This is from Polish archives.
So it's interesting, right,
because thousands and thousands
of Ukrainian peasants fled into Poland
and the Polish border guards
and other officials took notes, right?
And we have all of those notes.
So we have, like, this report
of what was happening
inside collectivization
from the perspective of
the peasants themselves.
So one peasant says,
"And if a war broke out,
the mood of the people is such
that if the Polish Army appeared today,
they would kiss the soldiers' feet
and the entire population
would attack the Bolsheviks."
Now, why is that interesting, right?
That is not the normal
Ukrainian peasant attitude
towards Poland at all, right?
That's from 1930, so
it's only a decade or so
after the Polish landlords
were kicked out the first time, right?
So it's a sign of how
bad collectivization is
that the peasants would be
calling for a Polish invasion.
And this is that moment.
March of 1930 is when the
Soviets actually feared war.
On the 17th of March...
It was March of 1930
when Stalin calls a temporary
halt to collectivization.
He gives one of his speeches
that is most remembered,
it's remembered as "Dizzy with Success,"
in which he basically
says it's going so well
that it's going badly, right?
He says, like, "Some of the comrades
are a little bit overenthusiastic.
Collectivization was always
supposed to be voluntary.
Let's just have a little pause, right?"
And that is because of the resistance,
especially in Ukraine.
It's also the same time, 17 March 1930,
that the Red Army is put
in full battle readiness
because they're expecting
an attack from Poland.
This is the moment when
they're most vulnerable.
It's also the moment
where they're most afraid.
So you have refugees
fleeing Ukraine to Poland.
You have the Soviet Army
in full battle readiness.
You have fear, but what you
don't have is a Polish attack.
The Poles look upon this and they say,
"Well, the Soviet state is mobilizing.
It's more powerful than we thought."
The Poles were always interested
in having more information
about Ukraine and about having
a Ukrainian alternative,
but the most they were ever planning for
was to use their Ukrainian agents
if the Soviet Union fell apart.
They were never actually
planning an offensive war
against the Soviet Union.
That was never part of their plan.
So I can say this pretty definitively
because I've read the stuff.
So what happens is that
collectivization proceeds
and the Soviets ask
Poland for peace talks,
and the Poles say yes.
And in July of 1932,
Poland and the Soviet Union
sign a mutual nonaggression treaty,
which is all well and good,
and it's a nice moment in
Polish-Soviet relations,
but from the point of view
of a class about Ukraine,
you see the consequences.
It means that the Ukrainians
are left all alone
in the middle of collectivization.
There's no one to whom they can appeal.
The kind of statement that I read,
there are hundreds upon hundreds,
thousands upon thousands
of statements like that
of Ukrainian peasants
going to foreign consulates
and saying, you know, "Please let me out
or please invade," right?
That's what they say to the Germans
and the Poles in the early 1930s.
"Invade. Let us out.
Invade. Let us out."
Over and over and over again.
But after Poland signs a peace treaty
with the Soviet Union in 1932,
there's no one to whom they can appeal.
So that scene that I set
at the top of the lecture
when the Polish border guard
is sending the Ukrainian agent
across the border into Soviet Ukraine,
that is in December of 1933.
By December of 1933, it's impossible
that Poland is going to
come to the aid of Ukraine,
and by December of 1933,
about four million
Ukrainians will have starved
to death in the collectivization famine,
which is our subject next time.
Thanks.
(thoughtful music)